So let's talk about some texture optimization pipelines here.
Again, we're in the project settings window, so just go to edit project settings.
And in the rendering tab, we can enable virtual texture support.
So what does enabling virtual texture support do?
So we can convert things to a virtual texture and we can essentially decide how the streaming method is affected.
So in your texture, you can change the sampler type to virtual color.
And you'll see in the content browser, you'll have an icon there that says VT,
just to show you that you've changed this to a virtual texture.
And so talking about texture creation and whether we are streaming, not streaming,
virtual, virtually streaming, you'll see the three different boxes that we have here.
And you'll see that we've imported the texture, a 1024, at the bottom one it's a 1000 by 1000.
But you can essentially see the texture properties by just double clicking the texture in your
content browser and you'll see that by changing the method, whether it's streamed or virtually
streamed or not streamed, this has an impact on how this resource is used and the size that
it is used at. And you can see that the resource size is massively different depending on how the
texture is then streamed. So if you're not streaming any textures, for example, that resource
size is going to be much higher than if you're trying to stream it at runtime and then even
lower if you virtually stream the texture. So again, this depends on your project requirements
and what kind of output you need and the visual fidelity of the textures that you need.
But just thinking about how you're streaming the textures can have a big impact on the resource
size of that specific texture. So when we talk about MIP mapping as well, depending on
the size and the use of the texture, if you're MIP mapping the textures, so say we've got a
1496 texture and you're seeing it close up and everything is nice and crisp and your texture
looks great, but then if you want to MIP map it, Unreal will take some affordances. So if you
then see a distance, it will optimize the texture so that it will reduce in quality the
further away that you are, for example. So going from 1496 to 512 at a distance,
we're getting a lower fidelity technically out of the texture. However, because it's further away,
it's less perceivable to the eye at a further distance. So MIP mapping can really help
when you're talking about resource size and imagine if we weren't MIP mapping and we had
1496 textures and they were just on every asset in the game and we weren't MIP mapping,
therefore we weren't trying to optimize the texture and everything was being rendered at its full
output, then you're going to have some performance issues. And maybe you want that,
maybe you want the crispest highest quality and you're running on the highest end of hardware
and you want to keep everything preserved. Again, it's the trade-off and the push and pull between
the desired platform and what this project is for. A real-time game that's on a console,
for example, will have very different requirements than an Archviz project running
on a high-end PC, which is a small containing scene, for example. So again, there are trade-offs,
but MIP mapping is something to consider there. And we can see with the different view modes,
with MIP mapping turned on, you see we're getting this fall off towards the horizon line,
whereas the MIP mapping when it's turned off, Unreal is still trying to render it and it
starts to be a little bit noisy. It's still maintaining its compression there and it's trying
to render, but you can see the difference more towards the horizon line as you see MIP mapping
turned on between on and off there. And this is just a good way to visualize the texture
resolution and what's going on with the MIP mapping here. So just using this render mode
will help kind of visualize the resources and where they are being spent in your scene.
And Unreal comes with a lot of good texture optimization view modes, which are good to enable
and disable depending on what you're trying to see, but this is just a good visual representation
of that.